all right so Toy Story 4 it's out maybe
you've seen it maybe you haven't but if
you have seen it this is my spoiler
review and that's a spoiler warning if
you haven't seen it for the warnings
don't take that long so that's done now
you've been warned this also isn't gonna
be a play-by-play she's gonna touch on
some of the themes I liked in Toy Story
4 they couldn't talk about because hey
spoilers I said Toy Story 4 as it starts
off it kind of shows woody and Bo Peep
it shows their departure which I love
because that's a great tie-in and an
explanation and it shows why she wasn't
in Toy Story 3 so that was solid so
after Toy Story 3 now all the toys they
belong to Bonnie
because Toy Story 3 was all about moving
on and Andy's moved on and he's passed
on the toys to a new generation but
Bonnie's in preschool she's really shy
so she's out of garbage she makes this
new toy she makes four keys Bonnie made
the perfect plaything a spork it's a
plastic spork actually it would have
been better if it was just a spoon it
was like aw lots of spoons a plastic
spoon but you know what boil your spoons
of t1000 you never did that I mean
either that total also for ki come on he
kind of looks like mr. bill mr. bill ask
your parents if you don't tell me for
key doesn't look like mr. bill and now
that for key is a toy through the love
and belief of a child four keys come to
life he's sentient and he's new to this
whole being a live thing so he's
basically like a child and so that's the
whole thing is that four key gets away
and Woody's like we have to get four key
back to Bonnie for he's important to her
so this is very important we got to do
it and among the many messages in this
movie one of them's is that's it's woody
trying to find his place and I really
like that it shows maturity on Woody's
part but wait there's more the movie
goes deeper so they go to the antique
shop were a really creepy doll that
looks like Annabelle's daughter she
seems nice she seems way too nice and
that's how you know she's probably the
villain kids don't want her she has a
broken voice box so yeah she wants to
take woody so basically this is now a
horror movies as I was talking about
with horror elements not just because
the ventriloquist dummies because those
were creepy as well but is the fact that
the plot is actually this villain wants
to take an organ from the hero and so it
could live that's horror movie plot what
he's gonna find himself in an icy
bathtub the icy bathtubs the only thing
that's missing which doesn't really work
out because even was like oh yeah I have
the new voice box I've taken it from
Woody now he stitched on his spine the
voice box works little girls like um
Tasha's are anyway
wasn't gonna work from the get-go I was
like if this movie is actually realistic
some kids gonna look at that thing be
like no because no kids gonna be like
mmmm here really looking for a doll that
maybe my grandma played with when she
was yeah bingo I liked it in the end
they made her sympathetic villain dagger
goons are creeps yeah she's a bit
intense yeah she wants to harvest
Woody's organs in the end she just wants
to be loved granted in the end Glenn
Close from fatal attraction just wanted
to be loved sometimes they can go a bit
too far but her little voice box was
messed up from the get-go she's kind of
had a raw deal right anyone watching
this could probably relate to that in
some capacity go any back Bo Peep I
really liked the page because Bo Peep
was the introduction to a new concept to
the entire Toy Story universe a new
concept to the consciousness of toys
even Bo peeps like what if we're just
kind of we're nomads what if we don't
live for kids we don't live for people
we live for our own happiness
that's huge it's a huge lesson because
everyone at some point their life's been
told not you're here and you fit in this
box and this is what you live for this
is how you're supposed to do it and at a
point we kind of realized yeah what if I
just live for me that's kind of the
lesson here because I mean I took it for
granted Oh toys live for kids but
they're also conscious so do they do
they always what if some of them are
like I don't want to do that nothing
wrong there's nothing wrong with living
for your happiness so I'm glad Bo Peep
introduced that and I'm glad by the end
woody chose that and that's where I
found the theme of this movie kind of
redundant to Toy Story 3 at first and
then I was like no I just it's a deeper
step into that direction that Toy Story
3 initially carve because Toy Story 3
was all about growing up and letting go
and Andy did that he grew up he let go
he passed his toys off to Bonnie but
still the toys are conscious of what
about them they just lost their best
friends so are they growing up are they
moving on and that's what this movies
about which I do wonder like where does
it stop where does the spiral stop
Bonnie can move on if her dad's like a
big manchild and he like plays with his
pocket watch or somebody was the pocket
watch of life I will say this an
unexpected turn I didn't expect to see
woody go yeah I'm just kind of leaving
at all I mean I thought Toy Story 3
wrapped up as a perfect trilogy I didn't
expect to for after 4 I don't expect a 5
doesn't mean it can't happen I wonder
what will happen well Tom Hanks returned
in some capacity I don't think he needs
to when characters find their resolute
and they go away like oh I have found
happiness now I don't like it when a
story brings them back into the fold
because I feel like that compromises the
happiness they found yeah it's just me I
don't want to clarify what I said in my
movie review for Toy Story 4 I said
something along the lines of isn't it
crazy that the first Toy Story movie
which is probably the worst of the Toy
Story movies is still great I wasn't
calling it I was indeed if you look
at it grammatically I was calling it
great one of them has to be on the
bottom and by definition the one on the
bottom is the worst of them the worst of
the great movies in which all of them
including the worst are grey dude it
might be toy story for I haven't had
enough time to process it at this point
ask me again in about 10 years you can't
get caught up on semantics with me in my
channel is just gonna drive you nuts oh
yeah I just I love Toy Story 4 I didn't
expect you I was looking forward to it
absolutely I had to look forward to it
but that was it that was a leap of faith
a blind leap of faith I feel like
Indiana Jones like all right click whoa
there's a platform there I did it again
I did think when Duke kaboom went over
that ramp and he hit his head on the
light bulb I thought his head popped to
be honest I laughed my hat's off I was
like oh he lived that's less funny I
mean I'm glad he lived i laughed
thinking the man toy died it's that bad
at me so those my spoiler ish thoughts
in Toy Story 4 have you seen Toy Story 4
what did you think about it when I read
that comment below let me know sorry I
won't be able to get you a child's play
review this weekend for the new child's
play movie I'll be out of town there
wasn't a screening for it in Seattle so
it comes out on Thursday I guess what
not gonna be here I'll be about this
present yeah that's me that's how I'll
be I'll be here to do a review to this
capacity not at all so if people are
saying it's a big waste of time by
Monday if I feel like it I'll do a
review for it if I feel like it I won't
know until Monday how I feel whether or
not I want to do a review for it that's
how I plan ahead by the day I won't know
what Monday feels like until Monday is
here let's see what happens and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]